hi it's time to get some work done now
I didn't turn on the grid yet so let's
do that right away and I can see that
ugly in-game fans we don't need that
anymore so just gonna turn that off
using vulgar boys invisible doodads did
I put that in the description last video
I don't know if I did that I should
probably still do that or at least do
that for this video again but once again
this is just finishing off small things
for the pirate-ship it obviously needs
some particles right now I don't think
this is going to be too much of a
problem however it does seem like I do
want the middle to at least be somewhat
flattened out because if you use
terraforming for the path then of course
you do want your ground to be somewhat
flat okay so I feel like this section
would probably be decent for the middle
here you know that's good enough so I'm
just gonna put this over here and do
sidewalks on the sides I don't know why
that just seems like a cool idea to me
really once again this is just a very
simple ride just have something on the
side and just because I am a
perfectionist I like to have everything
finished and don't want to leave any
weird-looking things anywhere
of course you're free to do that if you
want to because you are probably not
going to see these paths in any video or
any picture for that matter so it's
really not that important I'm just a
perfectionist so yeah that's that's just
me so let's see by the way I am using
Dutchess paths for this but it seems I'm
using the wrong piece here so that's not
really good it should be a quarter piece
quarter inner I think yup it is the only
thing to keep in mind while using this
set is that it's got the inner and outer
pieces reversed when you compare it to
shyguys SATs or branches sets for
example inner is considered the piece of
when you have a curve it's like the
inner piece so the smallest part of the
curve but this is the outside of the
curve is considered the inner piece
because its inner of the path but it's
kind of out of the curve its way to
explain I suck at explaining things but
basically it's reversed that's all you
need to know
now something about this set it's a set
that I rarely see people using but it's
a great set in terms of how flexible it
is and it's got amazing textures the
only thing that's wrong with it or at
least somewhat wrong with it in my
opinion is it's not that user-friendly
Thanks well that is partly also thanks
for the fact that it just has so many
pieces in it but of course it's also
somewhat unclear so if you're not very
experienced with the set it can be kind
of hard to work with it of course once
you've worked with it for a forum well
yeah quite a while you'll get used to it
and it'll become somewhat more easy but
really it's not that easy to use so for
beginners I would not recommend this set
that's all but it's really flexible
it's got stairs in it and weird curves
and sloped curves and pretty much
anything you can think of it's probably
in this set so most of the times I use
this set when I just have a general area
where I want to do something and other
sets don't have the pieces that I need
for example I think I used this set for
the stairs in Freneau Valley there was
the point of curry over there
that was terrible Croatia I can't even
pronounce that Wow and that happen yeah
I had to use this set for it because
they they were stairs and they were
curved and different kinds of slopes so
for that kind of thing you'd want to
have a flexible set but really for other
things I wouldn't really recommend using
this okay let's see so I'm just going to
have to fill in these quarters now
obviously there is a quarter one and a
quarter two because as you might notice
the textures are slightly different but
the texture is so small that I don't
think it really matters it's just a
waste of time if you try to change them
so I usually just rotate one piece
instead of clicking on the other one
just to have it entirely perfect and
this was a dumb idea because I have this
thing on the side here anyway so why
would I make a curve over there one
delete that come on you what is this
thank you oh damn I need to get this
over with
okay so small little
you kind of thing I don't that cue is
probably too small especially
considering the size of this of this
pirate ship oh well whatever just going
for it so first of all we do of course
once some turn styles so let's see
station James random things once again
because that sight is amazing and it's
got some cool coaster while these are
coaster gates though they would arguably
not work over here because their coastal
gates that makes no sense
oh yeah maintenance box is something
that I would need though just for that
little detail but I'm looking forward to
turn starts here we go with this work mm
it's probably too many of them like
three turnstiles from one pirate ship oh
well I'm just going for it
screw the rules I have green hair and
some turnstiles at the end of this there
we go that should do and then of course
we need some coastal gates bit but
before I play some small fences up we're
here so I think I'm just going to be
small well some random fencing for that
really I have no clue why this is just
one other part of the tutorial where I
can't really explain anything it's just
me doing what I like to do and what I
feel like doing on this particular
coaster so of course I'll try to give
tips along the way but I don't know
everything honestly and I can't say
anything about well I can't say
everything about everything there's just
some parts in making a coaster and
making a channel well surrounding of
that coaster that you just can't say too
much about okay so now it's part four
it's it's time for Costa Jose what's
that called again
Costa Jose queue line fences oh I love
this thing I remember that I used to
have huge problems with this oh my let's
play simply because I wouldn't know how
to work with this that even though it's
a very easy set but it's just something
that I usually use to at the Fastpass
but in this case I kind of want to use
it to keep the line
as a line and not have the line be too
chaotic so I kind of like the places in
the middle I don't know if it's too
realistic but I always like to do it and
with the rollercoasters this is always
something you can get away with because
fast bosses but nobody's gonna get a
fast pass for a pirate ship okay let's
see I think it's are pretty much time
for general path shenanigans yeah just
some small things fixing up things
before I had into foliage so first of
all adding a little border around this
thing and yup that fits that's great
because something else to note is I am
not sure if it has it in this thing too
I think it does like yeah it has the shy
curves because something that you should
note is that different sets you use
different kinds of curves now this set
just so happens to use this kind of
curve where it actually just had two
sides for a quarter curve and stuff like
that but especially in the sent you have
the shy which would be these things fit
with shy guys well things in general
yeah I'm pretty sure and there are some
other pieces which go with other sets
and I just realized that I didn't place
my hand on my laptop looping that was a
terrible idea
I'm sorry for that this it actually
works
actually looks a bit better because it's
more round honestly I think I'm just
gonna go with that it's not really a
quarter curve but it's effectively the
same thing so it doesn't really matter I
should not forget to place my hand on my
laptop
I should also not forget to buy a new PC
because basically the position that I'm
in right now is actually I've actually
gathered enough money at this point
because of my recent birthday and all
that and I still haven't actually went
ahead and bought the computer and if I
if I have some money to save I'm going
to buy a microphone as well because I do
want some at least decent professional
quality and I kind of subtly promised
people that I would actually I don't
earn that much YouTube money obviously
because I'm just a small roller coaster
tycoon 3 person but since it's my major
hobby I would return all of their
YouTube money that I earn for at least
or at least for the time being that I'm
such a small channel into my youtube
hobby so I would buy a new laptop and a
new microphone and all that to play
roller coaster code 3 and actually be
able to make higher quality videos so I
kind of want to go for that plus it's
better for all I go psycho and 3 in
general because higher crap better
graphics and all that ok so I don't know
if I did anything with the paths no I
did not something that I like to do
sometimes with paths is that I like to
add a small dark border and yes I know
I'm all over the place in this episode
it's just because many small things that
I need to address so what you kind of
get now is I'll turn off the grid so
it's easier to see it it's a very subtle
change but you've might have been able
to see it in my videos you kind of get
that dark little border around the
sidewalk and I don't know I've simply
why idea of more depth and more shadow
in general and it kind of creates an
illusion of ambient occlusion sometimes
and ambient occlusion looks great in
games I wish I had it I don't but it
looks cool so at least for the time
being I can kind of make it look like I
do have it using this neat little trick
so that's why I always like to do this
now if I'm not mistaken I use this kind
of sand and nope I did not apparently
oh wait yes I did okay cool and over
here is where the terraforming is not
not smooth anymore so I'm gonna have to
stop it there but that still looks
pretty cool and now I kind of want to
add that over here as well but just on
this side because I don't want to have
too much stuff of that going on because
otherwise it won't blend nicely anymore
really this path is too narrow to
actually do this thing on both sides and
especially on the diagonals if this is
something that works with straight
pieces but it's a bit harder with
diagonals but it's a very subtle change
but I think you can kind of see it you
can kind of see how the border around
this is just a little bit more dark and
not only does they kind of create a
sense of shadow on it it also just makes
the path look fancier really just
because there's more different kinds of
textures on it it just makes it look
more interesting and there's this even
work and too close to the Sailor yeah
let's see can I add this over here no I
can't do that I'm not too sure about
this but I think I'll just go for it uh
yeah this looks pretty cool now I do
want to add it over here as well though
because there's no space for that so
might as well okay so neat now
especially over here you can really see
that it kind of changed the way that the
path looked so that's pretty cool
now I also feel like I want to have some
planters over here but first I want to
add some lights I think so or not adding
planters is probably more important yeah
you should probably have plaintiffs
first so I'm gonna do that right now
okay let's see this is also this is
always something that you kind of have
to experiment with I never really know
what to do with this I think I'm just
gonna go with station Jim's gone earning
things because they're beautiful these
things are absolutely beautiful at least
in my opinion of course let's see and I
think it yeah it is higher than the
little board oh so that's good so I can
place it like that and it has the exact
same placement as everything in station
ships gardening so you don't have to
worry about the placement which used to
be the case in the old days you would
always have to watch out with your
planters if a tree could actually fit in
it so what you usually do is you'd place
a three first and then the planter but
these days we have the luxury of
actually being able to place the
planters down first so might as well see
they kind of evenly spaced out you know
I think so kind of want the fountain to
be visible to though but that's pretty
okay so we don't want to have this thing
go through the soil it's kind of going
through the soil here but it's not too
much of a problem I don't really care
and yeah that's pretty much it for those
planters yeah okay so let's see what do
we want to put in these things I'm just
going to get stationed Jim's going to oh
god I'm going to forget about some of
these that's I'm going to try to put
them in the description but
knowing me I'm probably going to forget
about something so if you kind of wanted
to get something and I didn't put it in
the description you can always leave a
comment and I'll update the description
and send a link these things are kind of
cool but they're the blocking the view
like we had such an epic for you going
but these trees are just slightly too
big so up with those things know there's
some other tree that I might want to try
it's the paper birch not it's kind of
small you know I think I'll go for this
though honestly since were on a somewhat
tropical thing but I don't think that
that actually has the corner placement I
might actually not be able to get the
placement right for this oh god that
would that would be terrible
there is of course there is a quarter
piece but that doesn't work out or would
it it would actually but there's no
quite a piece normal palm tree Oh God
well then that sucks never mind
station jim's gardening then well we can
always place a cherry brush I always
like to use this thing simply because
it's somewhat small but it also looks
nice okay let's see is that look okay
hmm that might just look too empty
looks very modern though like it was
just built which is also something that
I'm trying to go for but this all this
almost makes this almost makes me feel
like that too spaced out they might be
but I think I'm just gonna just gonna go
for it I'll judge it when I make all of
the foliage because once again you can't
properly judge the way a park looks
without all the foliage being built
because foliage really makes a lot of
difference yeah
now I think that I'll add the lights no
but I do want another Bank over here and
before I forget that I'm just going to
fill it I think I'm just going to use
the same benches honestly I don't know
how real-life parks do that whether they
use the same branches throughout this
throughout the park I think they use a
cup of different ones but also some of
the same throughout the park or at least
a general area so I feel pretty safe
doing this oh god now of course I forgot
its place these replace these things
last time so well then I'm doing this
again right now well I'm not going to
place anything and you're anywhere sir
let's see that looks pretty decent yeah
honestly I can't even remember what I
placed them last time
I think I placed some over here
I might have and one over there here and
of course some over here because people
are gonna have to look at the
rollercoaster they're gonna have to do
that they're gonna have to sit down over
there
just sucks
that's a lot better and there we go nice
and now I should also play some bins oh
and let's see we don't want any of these
this is the one that I want beautiful
yeah I'll do you don't need too many of
them and very important lights when it
comes to path works lights are just so
important like of course you shouldn't
forget them but you should also realize
that light can really change the
appearance of a path in general and
getting nice lights that kind of go with
the theme is something pretty important
and this is probably an abundance of
light so I'm gonna remove that one I
think though I did place a lot of lights
over there in that general area oh well
let's see I kind of feel like these
leave out hints lights get I think it
was from no it wasn't from this one it
was from 2008 yeah this one I think I
use this yeah I use this infer owner
value as well I don't know why I just
love this particular lamp and I don't
know if I want to place it on the fence
or not because one of the advantages of
placing your lamps on fences is that
they're not going to be in the way of
the path but they're also going to be
further away from the path itself from
like the center of the path but I feel
like this path is narrow enough to pull
that off but if you have a path with
sidewalks like for example this area I
always like to play some kind of in the
middle sidewalks and if this path were
even wider than it then it is right now
I would have probably placed the lamps
on the borders of the sidewalks to be
sure to be sure that every single bit of
the path actually gets some light okay
so it seems that this area of the path
is just going to have some special lamps
so that's really cool now these are
these are one of my favorite Boulevard
lamp so I'm just gonna use them over
here
yeah that looks pretty cool and one over
there
I think that's finished now yeah that
looks pretty cool I think it works a
little bit better with the trees too now
and of course I'm just going to put some
lamps over here because this area is not
very light it at the moment like that
yeah
and the cue line probably wants some too
but I feel like the cue line should
probably have some different kinds of
lamps these parkway line so actually is
somewhat good for this kind of thing
because they have wood and all that so I
think I'll go for this let's see you can
unload this good okay nice come on mate
this is somewhat annoying really I don't
think there's any way of getting around
that it's just an annoying placement mmm
this will probably do actually don't
want to over light the area okay what's
this okay there we go
I kind of want to place that some lights
on this side too
oh that was already very low oh well
that seems good
however it's not symmetrical and it
needs to be symmetrical so here we go
again
Oh gone this is this is absolutely awful
come on come on you can do it you can do
it I have faith in you oh I had it I had
it for a split second okay there we go
thank you very much and I think that
this area is pretty much finished at
this point now of course I do want to
kind of add something else something
extra what we need is some palm trees to
get in that sort of subtropical mood
that's what I'd say so it's time for
some small regular palms I don't know
some palm trees around the the pirate
ship might as well honestly it doesn't
look that bad
kind of like that except they're kind of
too big yeah definitely
that's way too big
and that's still probably too big hmm
think I'll do it like that
or not let's see kind of when I have a
small one please give me a small one
there we go thank you
would that look okay I guess so I don't
know what it is but it just seems like
as cliche as they may be the combination
of palm trees and a pirate ship is just
good because of many obvious reasons the
fact that pirates just like to be in the
tropical areas or at least according to
the cliches so we're just gonna follow
that because we're just a simple theme
park and I don't know what kind of plant
is I should use for this are we just
going to use the same ones just because
they're not awesome
plus they're pretty big so they're
realistic in that sense yeah I think
that looks pretty cool so I think this
area is pretty much finished at this
point however I do need to finish this
little fence over here because that
doesn't look very good let's see that's
from Station Jim's fencing and of course
it's important to get the color scheme
right it seems to be green on top and
the rest is just the rest is just brown
okay good and I think that's just a full
straight piece where's that full
straight piece there we go
ah very nice so when it comes to path
work I think that it's pretty much
finished or at least this area is now
might add some benches around fountains
I always like to add benches around
fountains or even flowers in some cases
so might want to mess around with that
but I'll do that in a later stage when I
round everything up and of course I'm
going to have to finish this area and
add some fix to that and then it's
pretty much foliage time and time to
finish the ride so once again
nearing the end - so that's really
awesome but anyway thank you so much for
watching and I hope you've learned
something even though this was kind of a
useless episode in which I kind of just
had to finish things that you always
just need to get around finishing so
whatever see you see you on the next
episode so till then bye